get started
minute
okay the time being 10:08 we will now
start with the public hearing on HB 1179
hearing um we'll ask up representative
bill
morning Mr chairman
committee my name is representative
Horan I represent Farmington and
straford County district
one uh the paperwork that I'm handing
out is the worksheet from the original
Bill 1179 prior to the amendment and
then the
information sheet that follows it is the
adjustment based on the amendment as I
understand
it originally the uh HB
1179 uh was requesting free entry to the
state
Parx for all retired military not
restricted by service or
Rank and then the amendment now that
that was to the tune of about
$115,000
and uh that included both retirees from
Massachusetts and Ro uh New Hampshire uh
based on information provided by state
parks which indicated that was where the
primary uh visitors came
from uh then as it I read the amendment
here it seems to eliminate the
Massachusetts residents and restricts it
to New Hampshire residents but adds the
spouses or surviving spouses of the
retirees which knocks that 15,000 down
to about
5,000 uh I would also mention that
the financial note indicates
316,000 I think it was
originally and I believe that number
actually included the number
of uh programs that offer free
admittance not necessarily associated
with the plan that we were
offering so as rather than 300 61,000
we're only talking about a few thousand
to add these folks uh to that $2 million
budget and that's it in a
nutshell I'd be happy to take any
questions I did you say there was an
amendment or is or not there's no
amendment to this right I'm looking at
there
is okay you have not seen an
amendment okay this is what I took off
your shelf I think I only all it
reflects the amendment yes what we have
is as amended by the
house but the fisc note is
not
okay
so HB
1179 as originally uh written is uh
roughly
$155,000 and that includes all retired
military regardless of service and rank
and it has uh retirees from
Hampshire follow
up so it that's with the what we're
looking at with the amendment that that
was made by the house because the
original amend the original fiscal note
says
361 million right the original physical
note I believe provided by state parks
included a number of their free
admittance programs not it wasn't
limited to just the uh the retirees that
we were dealing with or that were
requesting free admittance
for looking at the in the math the
paperwork that I shows the math that we
use which is a little different than
what the state Parx
used uh and we based that on the
information that state Parx Prov Ed in
2019 because that was the most current
information
available so I thought you were dealing
with the amendment because it was
sitting on your table over here so I
think we do have that yeah if if you're
not dealing with that then we're talking
uh
$116,000 uh just under
$16,000 for the retirees from
Massachusetts
and New
Hampshire if you take into consideration
the amendment the amendment seems to
restrict
uh the bill to New Hampshire
retirees spouses and surviving spouses
which cuts that $15,000 down to about
five in either
case seems like a reasonable
request
I have a
question follow
up so when you did this um revised
estimate that you just mentioned did you
take into account that some percentage
of those retirees are in the category of
being over 65 which are already free yes
okay
thanks representative Ames did you have
a question
no um anybody
else representative
Aly thank you
um well maybe we have some people here
from the park
service are you anybody uh what did the
Park Service have to say about this
since they have a dedicated fund
and can't spend outside of it for
renovations I they were at the original
hearing and uh don't quote me but
basically he indicated that that 361,000
could have been revised it could have
been a much lower number my
understanding of that number is it
reflects all their uh free admittance
programs all not just the little bit
that we're talking about about so our
segment based on the numbers that we
came up with using the
2019 stats was just over
$15,000 for the
retirees and it and it's limited solely
to Massachusetts and well it's it's open
to all retirees but they indicated state
parks indicated that the majority of
their visitors come from Massachusetts
and New Hampshire so that's what we base
the numbers on
but now what we have is just for New
Hampshire but including spouses that we
have no way of knowing that is what the
amendment reflects and that is it now
because of that requirement for New
Hampshire residency it eliminates the
Massachusetts residents
retirees uh and limits it to military
retirees that's qualified
retirees uh to 20 years or more give or
take uh the spouses of those military
and surviving
spouses uh in the number in in looking
at the amendment and based on the number
and limiting it to New Hampshire
residents that cuts that cost down to
5,000
bucks and some
change you're saying it cuts it down to
5,000 from this from 15 from 15 and this
360 361,000 was when Massachusetts was
included that that
361,000 was a number provided uh that I
believe I can't confirm this but I
believe that included State Park's total
expense or sacrifice for uh free entry
programs a number of programs not just
mine R Alman Mr chairman I really think
we ought to have the Park Service
explain
their original fiscal note which uh
126,000 if it's if we ignore the
spouses where's your 126,000 coming from
it's uh from their the formula that
they'd put
in about on the
9,533 military
retirees on and
an average visits per person of
2.65 per year and uh Park admission fee
of $5 which is the highest it's for the
most popular
parks
okay representa spillsbury
so uh representative organ one of the uh
papers you've handed out is a memo from
Eric power I guess and uh
that seems to indicate that instead of
2.65 visits per
member there would be more likely
0136 visits per member so that instead
of
27,2 54 estimated visits it's
8,246 it would seem that accounts for uh
the Lion Share of the reduction would
you am I interpreting that correctly
that is
correct
and therefore what that would bring the
cost to around
5,677 and well I have a vague
recollection that that's what I saw in
the committee report when this came to
the house
floor
else
okay thank you uh did you have something
else just one more thing on the uh on
the 2.65 visits that's uh my
interpretation of that is that they were
including all the military type visits
from Massachusetts in New Hampshire our
number reflects only the retire rats
that that
0.136 is strictly retirees does not
include any other
group okay that's all I
have thank you thank you is there anyone
1179 okay seeing none I'm going to close
why why is it there twice I don't
now
okay I'm going to open the public
hearing on HB
1391 and um we'll hear from the
uh Prime
sponsor
Coker thank you Mr chairman uh my name
is Matt CER I represent bellnap second
district town of Meredith and um HB 1391
is a bill that basically allows um new
vehicles to be inspected in their second
year after uh purchase so just a quick
example would be my birthday's in March
so if I bought a car right now the next
a new car like this month the next time
I need to get an inspected would be in
March in 2026 and um there is a fiscal
note on this uh bill it's um if you look
at it it it shows about the $270 or
$270,000 loss of Revenue um and that's
due to there's going to be about 83
fewer inspections every year when this
bill uh gets um implemented um so if you
look at it the way they got to that is
83,000 and right now a sticker costs um
$325
so you
if if you we have a contract with Gordon
Derby that's that's up at the end of
this year and my understanding is that
that could be renegotiated so the simple
the way that I look at it is if you add
about 25 cents per um inspection sticker
that's going to make up for the revenue
completely and uh this would be a good
time to do it since the the contract is
coming up and from a policy standpoint
the house and the policy committee
looked at this and said there's no
safety issue uh with this bill so I
would just hate to see a revenue issue
cause a problem with it because if you
look at $40 per inspection which is
about what I would say is about average
at 25 cents more on a sticker isn't
going to make a huge difference um and
that
$40 amongst the 83,000 inspections would
cost our citizens $3.3 million so it's
that you know I'd hate to see this bill
uh run into issues when it's 26 or
$270,000 worth of Revenue and it costs
our taxpayers 3.3 million so I'm uh open
to any questions thank
you repres
elme thank you uh this bordon gardy did
you say Gordon Derby yep there I I have
no idea how to spell at to look it up
but uh is this the company that makes
the stickers they have the contract from
okay
[Music]
this follow up yeah is this written into
law somewhere what the sticker price is
uh I I don't believe it is I think it's
just negotia in the contract but I'd
have to I I don't know that for for sure
I think there's somebody here that might
be able to speak on that a little bit
more detail hope so thank you
representative
ducet thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my
question may not be something you can
answer directly maybe some IND industry
folk can can answer but I I find it hard
to believe that a vendor would pass on a
an increase of 23 or 25 cents onto a
sticker that costs on average 40 50
bucks so what what I'm hearing from you
is we save our constituents in excess of
$3
million yes we save them 3.3 million and
I I would be shocked if that got pass on
to cons maybe we'll hear testimony but
I'm just curious about the 20 it seems
you uh anybody
else saying none thank you oh yes so I
have a question about in the the new
paragraph you know the last part of the
bill yes it says by a natural person as
the first owner does that mean that this
doesn't apply
to vehicles that are owned by a company
no we added um we added some language in
here at some point here let me let me
um basically we added language in here
uh at some point to make sure it applied
to a uh
company you can you show me where that
U so if you look at um page uh which
page is this uh page three if you look
at line Oh by a corporation yeah yeah a
vehicle purchase or a um purchase prior
of the bond of year by a corporation as
a first owner should be shall be exempt
from the inspection to the last day so
it's so it so it does not exempt
um so this extra time time applies to
fleet vehicles also which could have
significant mileage on them yeah well
and if you own a fleet of vehicles that
does a that has a lot of mileage on it
you're going to be I'm assuming I mean
just from good good corporate policy
you're going to be inspecting them and
and and taking care of them because if
you're putting a lot of mileage on a
fleet vehicle that means you need the
vehicle so I I doubt they're going to
neglect
it so follow up well that
that argument would apply to anybody I
mean how is that different I I I would
said the the
fleet does not
include um Vehicles purchased by
corporations the you know that's and
that that was an argument but
the if you look at the data I mean I've
had when I spoke on the floor about that
I talked about the data there there is
no um there there's no appreciable
difference in states with inspection
programs and without inspection programs
and I'm not even we're we're really only
focusing on brand new vehicles so it's
going to have even less of an effect and
in two if you look at insurance
companies I to my knowledge I looked in
a lot of places i' never I I could not
find where an insurance company required
somebody to inspect their vehicle and if
I were an insurance company and I'm
doing the numbers on that and thought
vehicle inspections vastly improv safety
I would probably require a company to
inspect them either way so this just
there's just not a lot of data that um
that vehicle inspections actually do
safety okay thank you thank
you you have a question yes just a quick
I just want to clarify and I know this
this is a the policy has been set by the
house so we're we're we're really
working on the numbers and I missed a
number that you said I know that the the
um the fiscal note says this is going to
cost approximately
$269,000 a year for loss of sticker
sales you said and and I know my
colleague down the end said reiterated
this but um I just wanted to make sure
it was it the the the consumers will
save $3 million per year in in
inspections with yeah with fewer than 83
with 83,000 inspections out you know off
their the sticker price such a small
portion of the inspection but yeah
they're going to save a ton of money I
just wanted to make sure I understood it
mrman next I have
Friedman
Mr chairman committee members uh Aubrey
Friedman I live in Bridgewater private
citizen I speak in support of this bill
um I lived in California till 2018 and
believe me that state does not miss a
beat when it comes to any kind of rule
regulation any possible thing they have
everything there and I never had a
vehicle inspection there uh that was
mandated by the state um until I
actually came here too uh New Hampshire
I was like kind of surprised there they
do have the smog inspections every two
years but even then they got rid of that
for the newer cars it's just not
necessary to have the inspections and
that's that and by the way when you take
your car in for maintenance they're
always finding things anyway so in a way
it kind of gets inspected every time you
take it in for maintenance there's
always something um new cars are very
expensive and if you can eliminate the
that first first uh year which is
totally unnecessary then it helps the
car owner a little bit so I think that's
a good thing and then lastly on the
fiscal note it's a very insignificant
amount if you look at the highway fund
and that uh other fund I forget what it
is the total amount that they pull in
every year it's very it's like
0.008% and 0.001% very tiny percentages
so I'm sure the state will survive
without them and they can just tighten
their belt a little bit and those are
the reasons I support the bill I think
it's a it's a step in the right
direction thank
you are there any
questions seeing no questions thank you
prol thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee for the record
my name is Tom PR from deur and prol I'm
here today representing Enterprise
Mobility Enterprise Mobility operates
Enterprise rentar National Car Rental uh
and Alamo rental car brands in the state
of New Hampshire through a network of
over 30 locations and under these Brands
they've operated approximately 3,500
rental cars and trucks in their Fleet
over the past 12 months um given that
the policy has already been adopted I
wanted to confine my comments to the
fiscal note and I think uh represent of
Coker touched on quite a bit of what I
said but uh I thought it would be a good
idea to kind of go through some back of
the envelope uh math here and you'll
have to bear with me because although my
mom was a high school math teacher it's
been a minute for me and I just want to
make sure I don't do any Injustice to
tarnish her reputation but if we uh
start with the
$270,000 uh fiscal impact as stated in
the fiscal note of the bill all right so
that loss of Revenue is based on as was
stated the contract with Gordon derby um
that contract uh is expected or is uh
expiring at the end of this year so
December 2024 with the option to renew
um I think it would be uh noted that if
this legislation passes the house the
Senate and receives the governor's
signature the department would have the
opportunity to renegotiate a renewal um
at which point I think there would be no
loss of Revenue to the state um so deter
to determine how the state would make up
the money I thought we would do this
math together um and just to make sure I
didn't mess anything up so the current
cost of the sticker is
$3.25 and each year there's
approximately
1.25 uh million inspections at 32 $325
which comes to a total of about $4
million um now so you subtract from that
82,791
we get to about 1 1.1 million uh
inspections or $3.8
million so that's how we get to the loss
of the revenue of that uh
$270,000 so how do we make up that price
right so we take the
$270,000 and divide that into the total
new number of inspections which is that
1.1 million and we would see an increase
in the sticker price for an inspection
of approximately 23 cents
making the new sticker cost going from
$325 to approximately
$348 okay so I think that's good math
right now I'll let you guys check my
work but as we look at the cost of the
sticker it should be noted that there is
nothing in statute to dictate um the
cost of an inspection right so those
performing the inspections usually eat
that cost of the sticker and include and
bake that into the total cost of the
inspection so as representative Coker
mentioned we can say the average cost of
an inspection I'm assuming you've all
had your cars inspected I don't think
you've ever had it inspected for
$3.25 I would say the average inspection
cost is around $40 so you multiply that
$4 times the $82,700 vehicles that are
not getting their first their car
inspected in the first year and you come
up with $3.3 million that would be kept
by your constituents and injected back
into the economy um so with for those
reasons outlined uh Enterprise Mobility
supports this legislation and asks that
you vote ought to pass um a couple items
I did want to touch on that were brought
up um mainly through representative uh
fellows but first of all this isn't a A
New Concept uh so the state of Rhode
Island has very similar legislation to
what's before you today uh new car
doesn't have to be uh inspected until
its second year and also the state of
Connecticut actually has a four-year
exemption for new vehicles
at which point you know they're
inspected annually And in regards to
fleet vehicles I know you brought up you
know fleet vehicles have high mileage so
rental cars right the whole point of
rental cars is to drive so I've checked
with Enterprise and the average number
of years per uh number of miles per year
on rental vehicles is about
25,000 um I will say that uh Enterprise
themselves uh they change the tires uh
when the tread depth is is at 430
seconds of an inch and that tread depth
uh is inspected at the return the
cleaning and inspection at the start of
every rental so I think uh you know we
should also remember these cars brand
new cars are under warranty for two
years and I think that this will
actually drive more people to to the
dealerships to get when something is
wrong with their car you know for
example I bought a new car last April
you know if I hear something going on
right now I'm like well I got to bring
it in and
for an inspection so I'm just going to
wait whereas if I had to wait if I was
able to wait another year I would say
okay let me bring that in now because
it's under warranty it's covered I want
to take care of that um so I think
routine maintenance will pick up a lot
of the issues when you look at the fail
rate it's it's minuscule for in the
first year I think of about
78,000 uh inspections I think only 200
failed so
again some some math I hope it was right
but uh I'm happy to answer any questions
you may have thank you representative
elme yes
um if you looking at the other side of
this the uh inspection
stations that also take care of our cars
in other ways and this cuts into their
revenue and nobody compensates them for
that in fact we're talking about taking
an extra 25 cents that they're going to
covered sure well I think I mean I can't
speak for the inspection stations
themselves but I think you know most of
them also do routine maintenance right
so they do yeah but I go in for routine
maintenance on I went in two weeks after
uh I'd had something fixed to get my new
yeah representative
shamberg thank you Mr chairman just a
quick question uh are there any
statistics on how many new cars
uh have a vehicle defect that causes a
wreck uh I I'm not aware of that not
being inspected yeah I'm not aware of
that I I do have the information
relative to our inspections and the
fails um and I would say that you know
for example model year uh 2022 vehicle
uh in their uh first inspection there
were 78,000 inspections uh 264 failed of
those the majority was for glass which
uh can refer to anything from chipped
glass to tinting to malfunctioning
window
mechanisms can you repeat those
representative
fellows uh sure uh in uh vehicle model
year number two or year
2022 uh 7800 ,1 156 vehicles in their
first inspection uh 264 fails uh of that
glass okay follow
up so if I hear that correctly more than
a third of them failed their first
inspection no no no no that, 78,000 yeah
compared to oh
264 not two I left my cell phone back
there but I would need the calculator to
do that Ma I I was thinking 264,000
yeah that would be a problem that would
be a problem I don't think we'd be here
today if that were the
case okay any we're all set thank you
thank
you the last pink card I have here is uh
John
morasco from the Department of
Safety
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is John morasco I'm
the director of the division of motor
vehicles thank you so much for giving me
the opportunity to speak to you this
morning um I think the uh previous
speakers have already covered most of
the content that I would speak to I just
would uh go on record on behalf of the
Department of Safety and the DMV uh that
we do oppose this bill uh we have
expressed that from a safety standpoint
um within the transportation committee
from a financial standpoint Point um
again I think the numbers that were
offered here um were right in line uh
with what I would offer the one thing I
do have to offer the committee today
that's uh a little bit beyond what was
in the fiscal note is Gordon Darby who
is the um State Contractor U that
provides the software and the equipment
to run the inspections um and give the
inspection reports um if we look at and
this is information provided to me by
Gordon Darby if we look at 2023 20 24
Vehicles sold in calendar year 2023
you're looking at a total of
119,120
um vehicles that if the bill were to
pass would not be inspected um that
following year that being said what's
the grand total on that based on what
$387,500
which um isn't all that um off from what
uh the sponsor has offered here here as
as a figure and um and so as far as the
consumer goes um Gordon Derby has also
explained to me that uh you know their
business is based on volume um so when
they enter into a contract they're
expecting um you know a certain
projected volume uh a change like this
bill would um impact that volume which
would lead to um some cost impact to the
consumer however uh that being said I
think Tom prol spoke to it um and I
haven't run that math but uh maybe as
low as 25 cents or less
um so uh that's that's essentially the
um you know the small amount of impact
you would have to the consumer so I just
wanted to put that on record and I'm
happy to take any
questions representative Aly followed by
representative fellows thank you can you
tell us um maybe you said that I'm sorry
I was distracted there um can you tell
us whether on the sticker price is in
loss
somewhere
325 I'd have to look into that because
we'd want
to add that as an amendment if it
is let me look into that or think about
rate represent Ames
um this
is
well you mentioned that uh I think if I
heard correctly I got bad hearing um
that uh your office had opposed the bill
on policy
grounds in the first round is that
correct did I get is correct sir that is
correct yeah and I know it's beyond the
scope of our review but if if if you
presented a letter or a statement or
something like that to that committee I
think everyone would benefit from having
a copy of that thank you representative
I'll be I'll be happy to get you a copy
of
that represent to set thank you Mr
chairman quick question and I'm
not excuse me I'm not sure if you can
answer directly or not how long has
Gordon Derby had the contract to provide
years 20 years 20 years
and do you know are there other vendors
when this goes out for an RFP are there
other vendors that Supply this service
or is it going to be an
issue that's a good question
representative I haven't looked into
that I haven't looked into that yet um
I've been in this position for two years
we've been you know obviously using
Gordon Derby during that time and while
before that um but I can conduct some
research on that for you thank you thank
you so
much uh we have representative PL and
then representative
Lee we had planned to exec this bill
this
afternoon uh right here we had plan to
exact this bill this afternoon we're not
putting any pressure on you for rances
in a timely fashion at all
yeah I'll I'll get these for you sir I
can get them representative Le
Lee thank you Mr chair thanks for taking
my question I'm sorry if this is
redundant but some of the testimony we
heard said that there was really no
statistical support
for uh inspections as far as improving
safety when we look around the country
is your I I know you said the department
was opposed to the legislation um do you
have any differing statistics or um
evidence that the inspections do improve
outcomes well I have a I have a document
representative that I can provide to the
committee that that um has the the
breakdown in a a given year of the
number of inspection failures and what
they're for um you know there are safety
items that are in there um so I think
the mindset is if you look at it
globally um then you would say the small
percentage of failures uh even on the
safety side um are not enough to prevent
uh a change like this type of
legislation but if you take a uh you
know family of four or um any family in
uh you know vehicle on the roadway um if
the brakes are faulty um if the steering
is faulty uh if the tires aren't where
they need to be and especially in New
England um one family matters so um we
would default to
that thank you may I have a followup
followup the only other thing I'm
thinking through as we discuss this is
it makes sense it saves families time
and money they have a brand new car it
should be safe um um from the revenue
standpoint though as somebody who grew
up in a state where we didn't have
inspections and then with my first job
moved to Missouri where they did my car
failed on like 16 points and so I was
without a car um so I had to figure out
how to buy a new car so at as a working
person that was a real hardship for me
and so I'm thinking about this as we're
saving money for people who just bought
brand new cars right so we're saving
them a small inspection fee but
everybody else still has to bear that
cost and maybe even has to pick up some
of like even if it's 25 cents to pick up
that cost so it feels a little bit like
we're shifting it from people who can
most afford to pay it to people who can
least afford to pay it so that's kind of
what I'm thinking about as as somebody
who you know when when you take that car
in every year sometimes you're like
really can't afford a new car I hope
this is going to pass inspection so I
was just wondering if you had a thought
or a comment on that yeah I think it's
um it's a great Point representative I
think it's a very good point from the uh
cost standpoint um also i' just like to
share that um since the last session you
know we we've been working um as best we
can you know I could Lieutenant J ly
from the state police this year along
with Ken chaput who oversees the
automotive uh equipment inspectors uh as
part of the state police and I read
those reports so they go out and do
audits of inspection stations and um
sometimes they do them when uh there's a
complaint that comes in sometimes they
go out and do them because that's just
on their list um and when they find
violations when they find that people
are being taken advantage of through the
inspection process um they send a report
to me and I sign off on it and uh the
inspection station is set up for a
hearing so um so there there's that
piece of it the other thing that we
worked on collaboratively um
particularly for the transportation
committee um was people want better
messaging um if you don't feel like your
vehicle actually failed the inspection
or you don't think you were treated
fairly how do you deal with that um so
what we've done is we've actually worked
with Gordon derby um and on the vehicle
inspection report that everybody gets
pass or fail uh We've highlighted uh in
a better position on that U document who
you can call the 800 number um they're
going to go through the state police and
then they'll be uh sent out from there
if necessary but um we're trying to do
everything we can to let consumers know
um if you don't agree with the
inspection there's a way to challenge it
we do take it seriously goes to the
state police and the DMV is going to
look at it as well and um audits are
being done on a regular basis and one
other thing I would share with the
committee is um a large dealership here
in in conquer we had the opportunity to
tour some months ago and um they're
really uh like other inspection stations
upping their games and how they uh
conduct the inspection so glass that you
can look through and actually see the
inspection happen um and video that the
mechanic doing the inspection goes
through and points to everything uh
within the vehicle to say this is a
green uh you're good there this is a
yellow uh it's not going to fail on that
but you need to get that done this is a
red this is why it failed and you get a
copy of that video so more and more
inspection stations are going to um use
technology and um it allows for better
transparency and trust and what we also
learned from that one particular
inspection station was that consumers
that go there that see the video they
tend to buy replacement parts from that
inspection station or dealership because
they have formed that trust um
so we're working hard to make sure
people have an Avenue to uh contest
something represent Edwards uh thank you
Mr chair um I think I heard you say that
the department uh opposes the bill on
policy
issues I I want to know if I'm it's a
good assumption then to think that
there's nothing in the way the bill is
was written though uh that gives you
technical concern that you would modify
any of the language it's just if if you
oppose the policy I I just want to know
if the if the write up of the policy is
fair and if you have if you take any
issue with the with the write
up it's a fair question representative I
think I think our biggest um issue is
the the safety part of it that's really
um what we're focused on I think we've
you know all all the um the speakers
this morning talked about the cost and
who shoulders it and uh how much it is
or isn't so we we've addressed that um
the only the only other concern that
might be there or or maybe not is from a
law enforcement standpoint with regards
to uh the stickers themselves but um I
don't I don't know that that's a top
priority at this point either
so follow up so so you mentioned safety
I think that gets back to the policy
issue I'm just trying to make sure that
there's nothing in the bill as it stands
now that you would uh require editing
the the document the write up is is
sound it's just a policy issue that
you're having trouble with yes that's
fair thank you
sir okay um anything new representative
Aly yes uh this isn't quite new but
you're the last one can you
spell Gordon gty or Gordon s or whatever
representative I I did the same thing
when I came into the position I kept
hearing the name and I T who who are
these two indiv ual um it's a Gordon
Gordon as in G correct g r d n Das uh
rby r and that's the name of the you're
welcome that's a great question I had
the same repres Ames did you have a
question no okay representative
fellows so my my question is um how will
state troper
well right now is there a fine for not
having a Val a current um inspection
sticker and how will the state troopers
and the police know if the um sticker on
the car that looks like it's a year old
is on a car that falls into this
2year category or it it could be a car
that that's four years old because the
models don't change and look that
different um great questions
representative on on the first uh yes
there is a fine for uh not having the
vehicle inspected and I don't have the
fine schedule in front of me I think it
might be
$62 72 um and then as far as law
enforcement identifying the stickers I
actually I would defer to law
enforcement on that um to uh to maybe
speak to it I don't
know speak to that I don't I don't I
don't know if we need to speak to that
do we what are we talking about the
actual amount of the fine no how how
they my question the second part of the
question about how when how will they
know if there's not a valid inspection
sticker on a car because if there's a
stick sticker that looks like it's a
year old is it on a car that was just
bought last year or is it on a car that
was bought three or four years
ago how do the cars look how do they
know which model year a car is when they
see it okay um I guess we'll invite
up
yeah thank you Mr chair my name is
Lieutenant Jay lry from State Police
Troop G we oversee uh one of the things
we oversee is dealerships and inspection
stations in the state and just to keep
brief representative U as clerk will you
please spell your name sure it's O
Apostrophe
l e a a or y l oh L okay
sir so this was something that we spoke
about in the procedural process um I
guess to answer your question very
briefly would be that if this
legislature were to pass it would be
something that would uh we would have to
address an administrative rules because
there isn't something already existing
in that process so that uh we haven't
determined should this pass how the
vehicle would be um either stickered or
have something on it to allow us to know
when it would be due for an actual
inspection oh so thank you followup um
yeah so it would almost be
like you'd almost you should give them
the the sticker for the year that's
coming
up and that would that would actually
take care of it but do you know ahead of
time and do you have those stickers then
everybody would have to have like two
sets of an extra set
of coming up like a preview I mean at
this point we're we're not the policy
committee the policy has been has been
passed all we're looking at now is the
cost to the state so those are those are
good questions but I think in in the
interest of what this committee does
it's outside of our
scope representative PL you may slap me
down because this is B is on policy too
would it help if if this bill would have
passed to have a new vehicle sticker put
on there so the police aren't chasing
well that's you're back to the same sort
of question she was
asking okay anything
you that's all I have for pink cards on
uh HB um 1391 is there anyone else in
the audience that would like to speak on
HB
okay and it appears that it ISS me okay
said I'm not an expert on it but I just
this is the section that comes after the
one that was amended by the okay I can
bring it up okay before I actually
before I close this
um Jennifer for has just brought to my
attention that there was the question
about is it in law is the fee in law or
not and um section 266 colon 2 which
comes right after this proposed uh law
it says the fee for inspection stickers
shall be
$3.25 for each sticker furnished an
approved inspection station the division
shall transfer 25 cents of each fee
collected under this section to the
motor vehicle air pollution blah blah
blah so the important thing is the the
$325 is in law section 266 col
2 thank you
Jennifer no
266 266 calling
two okay seeing no one else who wants to
speak on this I'm going to close the
1391 have to catch up with what you just
minut
I'm going to open the public hearing on
hb1 1278 and invite up the prime sponsor
Thomas
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee my name for the record is
representative Wendy Thomas and I
represent the town of marac Hillsboro
District 12 I come before you uh
presenting House Bill 1278 which has
already passed out of Health and Human
Services
unanimously uh I am also I have been a
therapeutic cannabis patient for the
last five years uh just for the record
uh we keep identifying conditions
allowed under the New Hampshire
therapeutic program since I first worked
as a rep we've tackled insomnia opioid
usage and anxiety we keep adding new
conditions as they become known and how
do they become known we read and we talk
to patients they let us know what works
I started in the therapeutic program
five years ago because of chronic pain
it was a car versus bike accident when I
was a child being in the program I have
also used cannabis for insomnia eating
issues gut issues PTSD and
anxiety I found relief from all of these
symptoms some of which are not covered
in the program I talked to many many
people about therapeutic cannabis they
want to get in the program they want to
see if cannabis helps their condition no
one in the therapeutic cannabis program
uses cannabis to feel high or inebriated
I spoke to a caretaker in Maine and she
shared with me a wise truth if you're
getting high on therapeutic cannabis
then you're using it wrong however the
biggest concern I hear is will I qualify
because I don't fit into the current
patient model excuse me uh
representative Thomas yeah we're
supposed to do the fiscal note so yeah
I'm I actually thank you because I'm a
little little confused this has never
happened before and and I'm sorry I'm
temporarily delegated to well that's
fine that's fine so so the other
committee agreed that this was needed if
you look at the fiscal note on line it
starts on line seven that's the
important information yes um the bill
may result in a 10% growth
increase uh by increasing Revenue up to
$70,000 a year if this
passes
yeah so and there is no expense to the
state involved in in that according to
the fiscal note there is no expense to
the state this would only be revenue
from increasing patience in the
questions well that's very easy thank
much
oh well I
guess I'm supposed to
start no pink
someone have have you provided a pink po
you
uh thank you members of the committee my
name is Michael Holt I am the
administrator of the therapeutic
cannabis program with the with the
Department of Health and Human Services
I'm here to provide information and to
answer questions if you uh if you have
them um I'm also here to uh Express
support for this bill on behalf of
former representative Jerry kerk who is
the chair of the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board at a recent
meeting uh that
board voted to support uh the policy
behind the bill and very briefly the
bill would add a catchall condition
allowing providers to certify patients
um based on their clinical discretion uh
in addition to the list of qualifying
conditions that are already listed by
name in law um we did a fiscal note on
the bill um it cannot be estimated how
many more people will apply for uh the
program
um if we had 10% growth um we might see
Revenue in in the range of
$70,000 we have a $50 application fee we
currently have 14,000 patients on the
program representing 1% of the of the
New Hampshire population
um the department has sufficient
resources to handle any increase in
patient load so it wouldn't increase any
costs operating costs for um for the
Department to implement this bill so
those are the highlights um I'm happy to
answer questions about the the estimated
fiscal note or on the policy of the of
the
bill would that application fee be per
patient it
is thank you are there any questions of
this Witness
no then thank you very much thank you
very
much is there anybody else who wishes
yes uh there is a question
representative elberger thank you um we
talking I'm not sure this is a fiscal
question so you can tell me it's done uh
are there any other kinds of programs
for which there is an application fee
for for somebody to
drug not that I know of um there
cannabis is federally illegal uh it is
not prescribed in the State uh providers
certify a patient has a qualifying
condition
um the insurance does not cover it um
New Hampshire state law specifically
says that no Insurance shall cover the
cost of this um the bill or I'm sorry
the law created the therapeutic cannabis
program as a self-funded program um no
general fund dollars go to support the
program it is 100% self-funded by
patient fees uh and Licensing fees for
the uh the dispensaries and the
cultivation centers um so
we the department needs to charge a fee
we have the authority to charge a fee um
we have not raised our fees since the
beginning of the program um we have but
we've removed many uh many fees along
the way ancillary ones that we don't
need so now that the program is mature
um the self funding mechanism is uh is
you represent roachford thank you Mr
chairman just to kind
of add on to my colleague here just
curious this so this this change in uh
1278 would increase revenues by 7 $2,000
a year do we do we know how much money
the state is
Raising by charging patients to
participate in this program the patient
part not not the not the grower not the
but just the patient
part the fee structure is designed to
not bring in any Revenue this is a
revenue neutral uh program it's 100%
self-funded um and so we're not
collecting any additional revenue for
the state
um and nothing's going to the the
general fund and perhaps I'm not
understanding your question well if I
may follow up so the fiscal note says
though in DET terminal the department
estimates the bill may result in up to a
10% growth increasing Revenue by $70,000
a year and that's that's by expanding
the qualifications in which people could
getum it is assume that with when we
give providers discretion to certify
patients for any diagnosis that is
terminal or itting not just the list of
20 named conditions in the uh in the
current law that we will see an increase
in patient registrations sure we don't
know how many we we can't know um how
many uh people would apply to the
program um based on this law uh the the
10% projection is is entirely that you
know we're requ we're required this year
um to in addition to saying
indeterminable when do we write our
fiscal note worksheets agencies are now
required to provide a range of
indeterminable and so this is we may
have an increase of up to
potentially 10% growth and if that
happened that would be the number okay
great thank you all right thank you
represent
Aly thank you so if I understand the
situation on the 70,000 that we're
talking about would come into the
Department of Health and Human Services
is to administer the program that's
correct and in our budget it's totally
you so in theory it's Revenue neutral
but could it potentially create
Revenue I mean the 70,000 is it going to
cost that much more to if 70,000 more is
coming in is it going to cost 70,000
load we don't know how many more people
will apply to the program it might be 10
people okay we're required to create an
estimate through in our fiscal note
worksheet um and we use a 10% growth
number uh if that 70 if if we get
$70,000 more money uh uh in an per year
we would consider lowering the annual
registration fee for patients for
instance we could uh begin a program by
which we have no fee for certain
eligibility categories like Medicaid uh
recipients or people who are receiving
SSDI so any additional revenues that we
would come in that came in if they got
to if they were at a level we may be
able to have some more policy options
for the program to give to to reduce
fees to patients okay representative PL
yes uh thank you foring taking my
question thank you for taking my
question um we danced around the fees
and at one point it wasn't clear that
you had fees but uh if you have a
$70,000 increase based on 10% increase
then you do have a fee what is it for
registering a patient into this program
it's $50 thank
you did you have a question represent
Aly did you have a
okay okay seeing no other questions
thank you very much thank
you I don't have any other pin card so
um is there anyone else who' like to
testify on HB
1278 seeing none we'll close the public
1278 are you going to be exacting
long
gonna no it's uh we are almost we
are half an hour behind schedule now we
are only 12 minutes behind schedule so
uh the time being uh 11:10 we'll open
the public hearing on hb1
1429 and I will ask uh representative
bill
thank you Mr chair I'm uh substituting
for the prime sponsor um uh uh of the
bill I'm the second on the list uh this
bill came from conditions in gtown in
Manchester and so there were four
representatives from gtown sponsoring
this bill but it affects much more than
gtown we have in this in um Sunday's
Union Leader that now comes out on
Saturday uh there was a an article about
three dams that are being are in danger
of being shut down uh one and the three
dams are Kelly Falls in
Manchester um the Greg Falls station uh
where Glenn Lake is formed and downtown
gos down Hadley uh Falls Hadley Falls is
probably going to be gone no there's
probably no way to save it it's it's a
hazardous Dam there's no electricity
provider there this it's too small to be
saved the the Federal Energy Regulatory
Commission when I said firk it's not
swearing it's Federal Energy Regulatory
Commission uh laws uh rules say that
unless you have electricity producing
there uh you uh the dam has to come down
and uh if if it requires fish passages
of some sort Hadley Falls downtown gos
down that's a big economic driver to G
down we have our Pumpkin Fest there the
the the the races with with the carved
out pumpkins a lot of people attracted
to that it makes the town Town beautiful
and if it goes away that unfortunately
may change the character of the town uh
we tossing around the idea replacing it
with some sort of Coffer Dam which is
smaller which would still provide that
small enough so FK wouldn't consider it
a dam uh Greg Falls is were Glenn Lake
comes from and a lot of properties
around that right on the lake well it
won't be lakefront property if that
comes down there's a huge impact to that
and Kelly Falls in Manchester is forms
namas Lake if I'm pronouncing it right
which is partly in Manchester mostly in
gos down same thing a lot of properties
there will uh get destroyed the
Department of Environmental Services got
a grant in I'll let them see to it to
the federal government for a couple
million dollars to provide a fish pass
fish passage at uh at uh Kelly Falls and
to truck up above Glenn Lake so that
could save those two dams and if if if
that's possible uh then there may be
commercial entities to produce
electricity there but no commercial
entity could afford to undertake
providing a fish passage and so they'd
have to be taken down in the alternative
because of the risk in that uh this bill
was created U and to in a past uh
resources and wreck unanimously to uh
establish a fund uh a dedicated fund
funded by $1 uh and to eventually
provide a mechanism for the towns or or
interested parties who can a bond to to
to uh borrow money from the state to
require to do all the maintenance or a
construction to keep something in place
um and what we could also Bond but this
may be another their mechanism to do it
and as I say this past so the question
before Ways and Means is simply do we
create the dedicated fund and put a
dollar in it uh and then uh the money
funding beyond that dollar will have to
come through the normal budget process
the Department of enironmental Services
I would presume would ask and it's its
allocation next year money to be put
into that fund it would go through the
the uh finance committee of of this body
and the finance committee of the other
body body and eventually go to the
governor to fund that that with
substantial revenues so there's
something there to offset the cost if
any town were to apply and of course
gown would be first in line because
we're the first being affected but there
were many other towns with Dam's in this
situation thank you thank
you representative
elme thank you the last time this
committee had the dam maintenance fund
uh which is being circumvented by this
uh
uh on in it on the they had less money
than they needed to repair the state
dams that were most in danger of causing
damage to places below it I haven't
heard whether that has changed but I
have have over the years seen a great
deal of resistance by Governors and by
by the finance committees to put enough
money in there does this um creation of
a new fund that would have a slightly
different purpose than the other one
um have any chance of getting money put
in it uh I'm not on finance committee of
the house uh I'm I'm in ways and means I
I I can't answer the question quite
frankly but uh I think with the imminent
closure of several of these dams and the
impact with the communities might spur
more support than the
maintenance fund
did that's the best I can answer the
maintenance fund includes things like
the whole Connecticut
River understood but imminent closure is
the alternative it as they say it may
spare interest that uh some future
problem that might occur may
rest so if for example in the example
you give if if this dam was transferred
to the town of
gtown um the town would be on the hook
to ensure that the dam was safe and
didn't collapse and and cause problems
Downstream yes and it's not a it's not a
small undertaking uh it the as I
understand I'm not a civil engineer I'm
a power engineer U this would require uh
embedding into the the rock walls on
either side uh because right right now
it's in danger of collapsing and the
homes below it are danger of loss of
life and limb and so it's it's it's a
hazard now it does the damage that
exists does have to come down the
question is whether it's replaced with
something smaller the Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission would not consider
redam which would provide some of the
recreation ability to survive but that
would have to be carefully engineered so
it is not a hazard to the people
Downstream
okay anybody
else
questions okay uh yes representative
fellows so we have we have um some
testimony from um Environmental Services
that's coming
out there's pin
card never mind we'll ask somebody else
okay okay seeing no more questions thank
PL uh now have a pin card uh for um
nhdes
good morning members of the committee I
am uh Corey Clark chief engineer at the
dam Bureau at the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services I'm
here today to comment on hb1
1429 and as as we've heard today
basically this this bill would create a
mechanism in which when the state of New
Hampshire has a state-owned dam and is
looking to remove that Dam there is an
option for the municipalities or other
interest parties to weigh in on whether
or not they would like to take over
ownership of that facility and
so but so prior to getting to that one
one issue that has come out of um the
house resources Recreation development
committee and also uh SB 539 which is
very similar to this legislation before
you today is that there are certain
state-owned dams that are in the middle
of say a state park or a state forest or
a fishing game Wildlife Management Area
that may not legally be able to be
transferred to a municipality or another
interested party so currently we are
working with the uh Senate to uh clarify
that language in SB 539 and so I just
wanted to make that comment but in
working with the the sponsors of this
legislation and the sponsors of the
Senate legislation the state of New
Hampshire is responsible for the
operation and management of 273 dams
throughout the state nhds actually
operates 208 of those dams so we're
given the burdensome inventory that we
have today we are always looking at
different alternatives to either dispose
of the dams or remove the dams to lower
that inventory so we can focus our
resources on those structures that
really need to be focused on and this
this bill would help create that
mechanism in in when we go to remove
these dams to allow other parties to to
take over currently what we do do when
we are disposing of dams um one example
is we are working with a buyer to
actually purchase one of our hydrop
power sites here in conquer we go
through uh the through RSA 440 in that
process which go to court long range
planning governor and Council in order
to dispose of that that piece of
properties but there isn't anything for
when we remove a dam so this this fills
that Gap the other thing that this bill
would create is a loan program I know
earlier we talked about the dam
maintenance fund and um I'm certainly
can answer questions on that on that
fund but this would create a separate
fund that would be appropriated solely
for the purpose of generating uh loan or
a loan program for municipalities to
apply for or other interested parties
that could apply for uh loans to repair
their dams now those parties would have
to be able to to raise local property
taxes so really those other parties are
mainly Village districts or something of
that nature and so it would create that
program in which um uh municipalities or
these other parties could could request
a loan that program wouldn't come into
fruition until about until 250 I'm sorry
$2.5 million is appropriated to that
program as we've heard earlier testimony
these projects are are quite extensive
when we go for full Rehabilitation and
so uh that seemed to be a value that
could kind of get things off the ground
but certainly if we are going to be
looking at funding multiple loans for
multiple projects um it's it's likely
that that value would not be enough and
we'd have to wait until the the money
was appropriated enough into that Loan
program in order to really get this this
thing going but it's it is certainly a
start and uh so with that just that's
kind of just a broad brush but I wanted
to open up to any questions okay
represent
Aly thank you you did a number of years
ago
on offer to the city of Lebanon that on
we take over a uh small impoundment uh
relatively small impoundment but that
would wash out probably Route 10 if it
failed which it was in the process of
doing on and you offered it to us with
no
money and a requirement that we do that
we fix it if we if we wanted to keep it
and since it is a uh very attract itive
recreational draw inside Lebanon among
the citizens there uh we did it so
um how would you
decide among all of the projects that
that you might get this one wouldn't
have wiped out I think any houses it
would have been a major transportation
problem in our region um to to have to
rebuild Route 10 right there right next
to the dam
uh that but
um but it wouldn't shouldn't have lost
hardly any life if it suddenly collapsed
and pushed everything down uh it was an
old IM uh impoundment for the railroad
to to recharge its water supplies as
they went
through so um would it be based on the
amount of lives that might be lost or
the amount of money that might be lost
if the dam fails how would you decide
among different
projects if you've only got $5 million
yeah I mean we we what we would likely
do is uh when the program is established
and we have funding in the program we
would at that point in time generate
rules administrative rules that go along
with it and within those rules there
would be it would be laid out how those
these different projects would be ranked
in the criteria to for for these
municipalities to um be accepted into
the Loan program and so that would that
would be part of it you're correct
likely one one element of that would be
the hazard classification of the dam so
here in state of New Hampshire we have
four Hazard classifications we have high
which is loss of life significant likely
not loss of life
but likely uh severe economic damage low
Hazard minor economic damage and what we
call non- Menace which is essentially if
that dam was to fail nobody but the
owner would know and so depending on
that's just one one uh criteria that we
would be looking at when trying to
evaluate these certainly as well the uh
the impoundment the economic loss if
that pound was to go away due to the
property around there and and other
issues as well associated with those
dams
yes representative
Le thank you I understand where the
second committee on this bill um so
perhaps I should have understood this
bill before now but I don't so I'm
hoping you can help me understand
listening to my colleague from gtown um
talk about dams that I live very close
to um made me think about the dams I
live very close to in a new way and um I
live right by Kelly Falls so can you
help me understand
the state owns the dam let's say they
own the Kelly fal's Dam um they it's
expensive to take care of it and so they
want Manchester to take care of it but
not give us money to do it I'm confused
about what
this so I understand this puts into a
process this creates a process for the
transfer of ownership of dams to
municipalities from the
State correct and so in regards to those
three structures I'll just briefly
discuss those structures and how this
would apply to that so within gwn on the
bcat quag River downtown gwn as you've
heard we have Hadley Falls Dam that is a
uh state owned facility It produced
Hydro power up until 2007 because it
produced Hydro power it has a Federal
Energy Regulatory Commission license and
so is it is regulated by FK and it is
regulated by FK which is yeah the
acronym for Federal Energy Regulatory
Commission it is regulated by them and
so FK came to the state because it's
been so long since we've produced hydr
power at that facility and said you the
state of New Hampshire either needs to
start hyd restart hydrop power at that
facility or move towards surrendering
the FK license and in order to surrender
that license we either needed to bring
the dam up to current standards or
remove the dam and so when the state
weighed their options the the the most
likely option was to uh surrender the
license and remove the dam because
Downstream we
own Gregs Falls Dam which is on Glen
Lake that dam is owned by the state of
New Hampshire it is leased to a
hydropower entity so the state of New
Hampshire actually receives revenue from
that lease to that hydropower entity so
a portion of their revenue that they
make when they um sell their power comes
back to the state and goes into the
damage maintenance fund that we uh
mentioned earlier Kelly's Falls Dam is
the last one that dam is leased same as
Greg's uh to a hydr power entity that
hydr power entity was going through
their relicensing process every 40 years
roughly uh they have to apply for a new
license through through FK they were
going through that process in in the
midst of that process learned that in
order to get the new license they would
be required to put in fish passage at
that facility at that point in time that
Lei decided it was too costly to do so
and decided to surrender the license and
pull out of the site and so that leaves
the state of New Hampshire trying to
figure out what do we do with this
location and so the the way this this
statute plays into these three dams is
essentially that decision we made with
Hadley had
this legislation been enacted we would
have then had to go to the town properly
given the town the option to take over
the site um and then other interested
parties and if the town chose to take
over this then if we had money in The
Loan program they could then apply for
the The Loan program to to get funding
to repair the
dam follow
up so my question
is so I understand a little bit better
thank you so much for walking me through
those three
dams and how they're related to each
other I understand that at one point um
these were money
generating um that's no longer the case
um they're expensive for the State of
New Hampshire to
maintain so the state of New Hampshire
would like to remove the dams to save
the state of New Hampshire money my
question is why is that the
municipality's
problem the municipality doesn't
currently own the dam correct if New
Hampshire decides to remove the dam it
could create water where there's
currently not water I understand but
aren't you
bound to not flood municipalities or are
you not well certainly owning owning any
Dam there's a certain liability that
goes along with that should that that
structure breach I think in in the
reason that the municipal alties have an
interest in these structures is because
of the property and the tax revenue that
is generated by these bodies of water so
you have Glenn Lake which has I believe
somewhere on 180 homes you have Nasi
Lake no I understand why the
municipalities have an interest in the
damn functioning my question is why do
they have a financial responsibility
isn't it the state's financial
responsibility it is as of right now
it's only if it it's only if if the
state of New
Hampshire wants to remove the if this
legislation was enacted if the state of
New Hampshire wanted to remove the dam
the municipality would then have to
weigh their options do we have the
financial resources to request a
transfer to have the state transfer that
Dam to us otherwise do we let the state
continue moving forward with their plans
on removing that structure and let the
state take care of what they need to
take care of it's a mechanism for the
the town to essentially interject and
decide hold on we want to take over that
structure
I I think U um I'm familiar with the
gost toown um Dam there and I can see
the problem the state will say okay we
have a problem we're going to remove
this Dam and um you know so that we
don't have a breach problem but
basically once they do that it's going
to look very ugly up there so what I'm
trying to understand well that's where
the town comes in and says hey no we we
want to make sure this looks good so we
we'll take responsibility can they ask
the question a different way sure in how
is this not downshifting the cost of
running dams to towns in New
Hampshire aren't you just saying we
don't have money to pay for this as the
state of New Hampshire how about the
towns all pay for
it is that what this legislation
does if you want to just introduce
yourself yes I would I'm rainy peler I'm
the director of The Water Division at
Dees of which the dam buau is part of as
far as downshifting this isn't something
that we are requiring when we look at
the state own dams that Corey just
talked about we have
273 of them 208 we operate we've done
calculations looking at right now if we
were to just address all of those DMS we
have a deficit or a need for around $400
million if we deal with a 63 High head
the dams that we deal with we're looking
at to bring them up to current standards
to protect life safety and
infrastructure somewhere around 300
million so the state isn't looking to
downshift these what we're trying to do
is be fiscally responsible for what
we're going to maintain so if we have a
dam any of the three dams you're talking
about in gtown our choice is from a
fiscal perspective of state revenue that
the
the proper option would probably be to
remove it it's a run-of the river dam
it's not needed anymore but over the
years because of the benefit of its use
and hydr power it created empowerments
where we had like cor he said about 170
or 180 homes on it so obviously the
implication would be if that became a
run of the river again with no Dam then
in fact the revenue that was generated
by the taxes for that waterfront
property if you will may be drastically
reduced people may go and appeal the the
tax rate that they're getting on but we
don't look at removing dams just
willy-nilly we look at dams because it's
more cost effective to remove than to
repair for years you know you think
about dams like wi basaki and Lakeport
you know you think about the millions
and millions and millions of dollars
that that Lake generates people that
live on that empowerment which is very
large as you all know don't pay a dime
the state repairs that we pay for all of
the 273 dams that we own at some point
in time we have to be very cognizant and
aware of the importance of maintaining
and fixing our high Hazard dams that if
they fail could actually cause death or
millions of dollars in infrastructure
depending on the size of the EMP moment
so we're not looking to downshift we're
trying to be practical practical about
the money we have every year we get
somewhere around $30 million in the
capital budget as you folks probably
know certainly better than I probably we
usually capped on a Statewide basis to
somewhere at 120 to 125 million the
capital budget it's going to be even
tighter this year you've heard me say
that we had at least 300 million in high
has a damn debt we will again put in a
budget for look for $30 million or
somewhere in there so we can maintain
these high-risk dams and so I get very
concerned about when we come before a
committee like this and we're talking
about Appropriations and putting money
in our budget as you well know when we
put a budget together which is going to
be Mighty lean again I can see this by
any them that we get concerned that when
you look at the Overview at 30,000 ft on
the dees budget in totality that if
we're going to put in now for another
two $2.5 or $3 million for this Loan
Fund we have real concerns about that
thank you uh representative spillsbury
thank you Mr
chairman so uh I also am sort of
scratching my head wondering why a
municipality would want to take on the
liability but I understand that the bill
um leaves it up to the municipality to
decide whether to initiate the
process my question is the bill has four
sections it
uh in section one it provides that
there's a process of onee notice and it
calls for rule making in section two it
creates or establishes the uh the
revolving Loan
Fund three just uh makes a reference uh
where it's needed elsewhere in
law and four makes the appropriation of
$1 so am I right in surmising that
without the revolving Loan Fund
component of this
bill we're only left with section one
and that would essentially not achieve
anything um so why if that's
true why would we move the bill forward
this year
rather than wait for a budget Year and
have it reviewed by the uh finance
committee in other
words I don't see the point of creating
a fund and putting a dollar into it and
then expecting some future legislature
to decide whether to put $2.5 million
into it and $2.5 million is the
threshold below which it's not activated
so the whole exercise seems premature
and
well I I think so for the first section
regardless of the appropriation the
first section would still be but still
work re without without um without
Financial
um money put into it so the first
section you would still be able to
transfer dams throughout the state to
you could still work through that whole
process of allowing municipalities or
other interested parties to take over
the second section is you you're correct
in in the fact that we would have to
wait until the money is appropriated in
order to really kick that section off um
I think it
just I don't want to speak for the the
sponsors of the legislation but I think
it was a an Avenue to get this this
going so that it could provide something
for for the municipalities should it get
appropriated sometime in the
future follow up please follow
up so I'm inclined to think
that sections 2 three and four should be
evaluated in the context of whether
there's actually a will either in one
shot o or over several years to
appropriate $2 and A5 million dollar
otherwise it's uh it's essentially
irrelevant is there any grounds for
passing the bill amended so as to uh
retain only section one and drop
sections 2 3 4 does that achieve
anything useful as as far as the
Department's concerned as as far as the
Department's concerned that would still
provide the mechanism for the State of
New Hampshire to offer these dams if and
when we decide we the best course of
action for the State of New Hampshire is
to remove this structure would still
provide a mechanism for the
municipalities or other parties to take
structure just as a followup I mean if
sections 2 three and four stayed in
there um and they weren't funded it
doesn't doesn't hurt anything the town
would have or city would have to decide
whether they can afford to take it on
two sides of the coin it doesn't hurt it
doesn't do anything well it right except
that if it does get funded it's good to
go it's ready to
go representative plus sounds like a
good candidate for hp2 when the time
comes couple of points first of all uh
chairman janigian you said that uh the
loss of these dams could result in
something that's ugly it's well beyond
that the economic impact is
huge uh economic impact downtown gos
down all all of the all the recreational
uh events going on the the businesses
gets attracted to downtown from that all
gone and so that and all of the
lakefront properties in Two Lakes are
destroyed essentially the value is
destroyed huge economic value and uh I
would urge my colleague to
push ahead and if it doesn't it does if
if if and I believe the imminent closure
of Demands might spur Finance committees
to do something where they hadn't in the
past but the mechanism needs to be there
representative elberger thank you Mr
chairman this is a a public hearing
right we're doing a work session on this
later correct thank
Ames
turning to section one and and your
letter the letter from commissioner
Scott that we received um it appears
that there are changes are are needed
from the perspective of Dees in that
section um
and um I understand that one of them is
that there's language uh that references
any state-owned Dam and there's a group
group of dams that may not be subject to
that should not be subject to this
procedure that's my understanding and
Lang and I guess language is needed for
that I'm asking that question also
there's the mandate to the
department that uh one year prior to
removing any Dam the department shall
offer to tr transfer ownership and that
too as I read the letter um should be
limited or there should be exceptions
could you speak to that and do you have
a
specific a specific proposal to make
those changes in this bill or does
anybody sure um so speaking on that as
as a you you said in in the letter of
testimony it does call out potential
issues and as as I mentioned earlier
those issues are really kind of centered
around these large state-owned Parcels
in which you have a dam that's owned by
the state that's in the middle of that
parcel there's also some possible
environmental um issues that come up
primarily with some of the head of Tide
dams that you know the removal might be
a greater benefit to the state than than
uh transferring it to the
municipality like I mentioned there's
almost identical legislation in the
Senate right now and we are working with
the Senate to clarify that it just
because of the way the the process is
playing out um so I am currently working
with the Senate to clear clarify some of
these issues likely in paragraph two of
section one is is likely where we're
going to to add some of that language so
that if there's certain circumstances
such as I just mentioned a dam in the
middle of a large State on parcel those
would be exempt from being offered up
just like SE paragraph two lays out the
commissioner has as it stands now has
the authority if there's a risk to life
or danger to to say no we're not doing
the transfer we're doing the removal
this would be something similar like
that it would just apply to other things
um and just I just want to take a minute
to just clarify the um some of the
things in gtown so like I mentioned the
state of New Hampshire owns those three
structures um we heard testimony earlier
about a uh a grant that we are working
on that is a $20 million Grant the state
of New Hampshire is working on and what
that Grant would do is we are not
interested in removing either Kelly's
Falls Dam or Greg's Falls Dam so our our
goals and objectives are to keep those
structures into perpetuity the reason we
are going after a $20 million Grant is
because that Grant would allow for fish
passage construction at the downstream
Kelly's uh Dam once that fish passage is
implemented we could hopefully get
another hydrop power producer to take
over that site with a new firk license
so that Dam would be generating power as
it is today still owned by the state but
it would be leased out to that entity as
part of that fish passage we would also
be implementing a truck and trap system
that would allow fish to be moved from
that location Upstream of Gregs Falls
Dam therefore the state of New Hampshire
wouldn't find themselves on the hook
down the road of having to put fish
passage at that location but it could
still remain as a hydrop power site and
also remove Hadley Falls Dam and to
address some of the unsightly issues
that sometimes come up as part of these
removals is we would be doing a full
River restoration program so that would
restore the stream channel in that
vicinity along with providing public
entities such as walkways uh handicap
access to the river and other items in
that stretch where the impoundment was
to help enhance that as part of the
whole dam removal process so I just
wanted to clarify what the state of New
Hampshire is looking to do currently uh
at on the pasca quog we should hear
about that Grant really any day now but
that just wanted to clarify some of
that okay
followup I guess this is a followup I
mean that was interesting and useful
information but it wasn't I think um the
question I was asking was amending
amending the bill and you referenced the
Senate process that you're engaged in
with the Senate on a almost
identical or similar bill um if we're
going to handle this thing we we need to
make these Corrections and you know I
feel positively about this bill but I I
don't in order to move it back out of
the committee and knowing that there
these uh issues I'm not sure how we're
going to handle this but I at least we
need to get that information uh if you
have
particular um changes to the Senate bill
that we should see we should see them
not written out at this time it's it the
the the conversation with this the
Senate on the Senate Bill took place
last Friday and so it's
it's we're still working through the
language I don't have anything um
definitive to to present at this time on
this well
okay
representative yeah have to continue on
that
General
listening to the dialogue
here I'm a little bit confused I let's
take you have the state-owned property
nothing requires you to sell anything in
this
bill it does offer the ability to offer
tax if say the the generating plant the
there's a few of them floating around
the go one and G toown is one that does
permit that but it's merely an offer
it's not an obligation that you must do
you must provide that but you can just
say hey it's for sale somebody want to
buy it if you don't want to buy it we're
going to blow it
up is that
correct so the way the legislation is
proposed it would only apply to
situations in which the state of New
Hampshire was going to remove the dam so
if we decided we are we are going to be
removing the dam we must offer it to the
municipality first if the municipality
refuses then we can offer to other
interested parties now those other
interested parties a pretty narrow um
group but we would then have to do that
to allow them to take over ownership
prior to us moving through the process
of removing that Dam
so there's no obligation uh on uh
there's no U 28a issue of mandating that
the community take it over because they
can just say ah blow it up we don't care
no uh just follow one one further point
but if the community doesn't want to
take it over an entity that is approved
by the community to provide power to the
town let's just just the current name
that's Out There community power for
example they could go ahead and purchase
it use it to generate uh so-called green
uh although it's not really green it's
electron well anyway it's yeah they
power they could purchase it because
they have the ability to charge the rate
payers and and pay for it and then
generate it and all that is that
correct
I don't know if if that
would in in that instance if that if the
state would then have to transfer it to
that entity because that entity does not
well you're right they they can generate
rates and through the the rate payers
but I'm not sure if if that would apply
however in EV any Dam that we are
looking to remove the option is always
on the table for any entity to come in
and request to take it over it just
just I mean the way I'm reading this it
says municipality it doesn't say any
entity yeah and well what Mr chair yes
what was just U intimated was there was
no need for this bill because you can
already do it look at line 25 on we can
already do it we just we're not required
to do
removal okay representative duet just
thank you Mr chair just a quick quick
question with the discussion that's
going on what is the process for Dees to
eliminate a
dam I'm I'm hoping it's a fairly lengthy
process if we have 273 dams and Dees
decides we're not going to take care of
273 dams what is that process and how do
you come to that conclusion so so um the
when we when we look at the when we look
at the inventory we we we look at it to
you know what dams are viable from an
economic and ecological standpoint what
dams are no longer Meeting those goals
they're they're no longer meeting the
original intent of those dams and at
that point in time that's when the
decision is likely
made when that Dam in particular needs
to be rehabilitated so it doesn't meet
current criteria
we then look at it do are we going to
fix this Dam or are we going to remove
this Dam cuz more than likely it always
cost more to fix the dam than it is to
remove it and so trying to use those
resources wisely and say we can fix two
out of the three dams we remove one we
fix two we fix these three dams on this
Watershed but the length of time that it
takes to actually get a shovel in the
ground from when that decision is made
is years and years in the making because
not only do we have to make sure that we
have the proper Revenue to do so but
then we also need to go through all the
environmental permitting process that
anyone else would have to do which look
takes into account what will the river
look like once the dam is removed if the
dam is removed is there contaminated
sediments that need to be addressed um
how how is it going to impact the the
Ecology of that river system or that
Lake system when this dam is removed so
all that needs to play out in the the
normal regulatory process through the
permitting that takes
place follow up quick followup and and
that leads to part of my question and
you've answered some of
it logic would tell me like you just
testified to that there are some big
costs associated with removing a dam and
and as limited as the budget is how does
that play into the decision-making
Factor let's say you want to get rid of
Dam a or Dam B the town doesn't want to
take over ownership of that and it's
going to cost $18 million to mitigate
the
situation H how do you go through that
and and specifically the decision to to
uh remove that dam is made by Dees by
whom at Dees is there a board is it the
commissioner's decision who makes that
final decision or who who shares in that
decision decision making
process that decision-making process
happens at all all all levels within
Dees everything from from the staff
within my group all the way up to the
commissioner of trying to figure out
what is the best means of moving forward
with this the other the other thing
whenever we go to do any Dam
Rehabilitation or removal is also trying
to get the funds to do so and so through
the capital appropriation process is
when we put forth the projects we are
going to like we're likely to do whether
that's Rehabilitation or removal and so
that goes through the process as well
the the other thing when it does come to
Dam removals is there's more money out
there federally for Dam removals than
there is for Dam Rehabilitation we do
tap into both Avenues so we we do tap
into uh FEMA grants through the high
Hazard potential Dam program for Dam
Rehabilitation projects but then as I
mentioned earlier we do tap into uh
restor projects or restoration funding
that can be applied towards dam removal
projects so in either way we try to we
try to Target our money wisely to uh to
get the best
outcome representative
elberger thank you Mr chairman as
finding as fascinating as I'm finding
the
conversation as far as I understand
we're supposed to be looking at the
fiscal implications for for the state
and I would like to try to get the
conversation back there thank you
represent representative elme did you
have a question representative Le was
leapley thank you Mr chair thanks for
trying to help me understand this very
complex and important issue um it seems
like investing in this way from our dams
is a little bit complicated right rivers
are long and they're full of water and
water goes where water wants to go right
um you're an engineer you are fighting
quite a battle when it comes to water so
I guess I'm wondering like how could one
possibly pass this off to municipalities
so let's say that like Kelly Street or
Kelly Falls is Downstream from I don't
know how many dams what if Manchester
would like to do something with our dam
but you know three municipalities up
River decide to do something different
so I guess I'm wondering how how
municipalities could
possibly manage dams isn't this
rightfully something that the state
should
be dealing with and can you explain to
me how that would happen yeah I I think
the the concept that we're trying to
pass us off on Miss ality is is not the
issue what we're trying to achieve here
is we have a certain amount of money
that's available for dams if we get to a
dam where it's more cost effective to
remove than to rebuild which is the case
in hadly Falls that whole Dam would have
to be torn down big money and then
rebuilt it makes no sense fiscally and
we we would it would be impossible to
justify when we go to get that financed
through the budget we are not requiring
municipalities or passing this down as a
28 issue that they have to take over a
dam what we are telling them what this
bill does it gives us the ability to
offer the municipality if they so choose
to take over the dam and move forward
with the appropriate appropriate
maintenance so that dam is not an unsafe
issue so so there's no requirement that
the municipality has to take it over but
in the big picture for us as you just
heard earlier we have all of these dams
we have to prioritize which ones should
be repaired or what's more cost of
effective which one should be removed
what this bill does again to reiterate
is it affords
municipalities the ability to say that
dam is very important to us we would
like to take it over this bill allows us
to transfer that property and with it in
sections 2 three and four in the Bill of
proposing to offer a loan program which
may make it available to a municipality
like we do with all of our water and
wastewater loans we spend millions of
loans so to clarify this isn't mandating
a municipality to take it over it's
providing an option I understand that I
just want to be clear that what if you
we're are so if the process goes from
here to here we're already here I'm I
want to back up the process up here and
say if we would raise
taxes
to be able to care for the Investments
our state has made then at the state
level then we wouldn't be looking to
loan money to the cities to take care of
our dams so I'm just thinking that this
doesn't really this is kind of
inappropriate that this has ended up
here so it seems to me that that the
revenue does not exist to take care of
our dams and therefore we're looking for
this way to solve the problem so I just
want to say out loud what I'm thinking
thank
you representative
elme
thank you I think that said most of what
I was going to say there are poor
towns that don't have the money to be
able to take something over Enfield was
one of them a number of years ago uh and
then there are wealthy towns that can
somehow do it in order to avoid large
mud pits but I was wondering uh in any
of these cases of REM removal would
there be
flooding into the low Ling areas around
housing so in most cases when when the
dam because the dam is there take a any
run-of the river dam that dam is already
holding back a certain percentage of
water and so when there is a flood event
that flood of bent is compiled on top of
the water that is already sitting there
so
so more than likely depending on
different circumstances but more than
likely when you remove that Dam that
impoundment is no longer there the river
is still there in its natural water
course whatever that may be but that
flood event is on top of that natural
water course so you don't have a
compounding event and the other thing
you also don't have is you don't have a
risk of a breach wave occurring from a
damn failure so during the course of the
flood you're not you're not in you're
not putting pressure on a man-made
structure that then needs to hold back
that flood water and and release it in a
manageable fashion so by removing these
in most circumstances you're actually uh
addressing a potential flood problem and
issues thank you um I think um we might
be getting more into policy again um I
have a revenue question okay good
uh thank you so one of the things you
mentioned is that one of um a dam that
had a hydro plant on it is doesn't want
to renew because of the fish ladder
issue and that you had another of these
three that we were talking about had at
one time been a power plant but it
wasn't it's not anymore so I'm I know we
have existing dams that generate power
and I think
there like 30 something of them or and
are how many of those are going to face
the same
issue so when we look at just and excuse
me I'm sorry to interrupt the reason I'm
asking this is because one of our
Revenue sources is a utility tax on
these stamps or these power generating
facilities well I'll let him answer but
my understanding is they have to be
operate if they're operating they'll be
ATT they they if they're not operating
and they haven't operated for a while
that's where the issue comes in but I'll
let you so and and so I'm thinking how
many of the existing ones we have are
going to because of this fish ladder
issue are going to stop
operating so I don't know how many Hydro
regulated dams there are in the state of
New Hampshire that are regulated by FK
the state of New Hampshire however has
11 dams that are regulated by FK nine of
those dams are currently producing hydr
power and so this would this issue of
the state owning a dam that is leas to a
hydropower entity and the hydropower
entity no longer wants to be involved
with that site pertains to nine
structures in the state there are
certainly many more hydr power dams all
throughout the state of New Hampshire
but the the state the state owns nine
active hydrop power sites and sites that
have FK
licenses representative PL I'm careful
not to ask question my question had to
do with how many of them are facing or
could are possibly going to have this
fish ladder issue that will make them
want to shut down it currently the only
only one that's that's truly facing that
issue that the state owns is is uh
Kelly's falls down however as these
sites get
relicensed um that's when the resource
agencies can step up and say look we
want to see Fish passage at this
location and some of those sites are
going through relicensing some of them
will have relicensing down the road so I
don't know what the answer will be 5 10
years down the road as to what sites
will be required to have fish passes
because a lot of times what happens is
it's it's a compounding effect if you
can get fish passage down at LOL and
lawren
and up into Manchester then the fish
move up and so a lot of the agreements
that the hydr powers have with the
resource agencies us fish and wildlife
fishing game Noah Fisheries is that once
fish are able to
move through the the structure
Downstream of the structure you own then
passage represent PL I'm careful not to
ask questions because I testified one of
the other well you can't ask questions
I'm not you okay okay that's I just a
preface that I'm not asking questions
I'm making statements well you can't
make statements either well course I can
I testified so I'm continuing with my
test testimony I haven't recognized you
there is that correct
okay we can do it in the work you can
make statements in the work
session okay are we all set on the this
topic okay great thank you very much
thank you um that's it for pin cards is
there anyone else who would like to
HB go back now could
should
okay
appearances okay representative PL is
yes coming up to testify for a second
time thank you for rec recognizing me
and allowing me to speak further uh
we've been working uh the cross down
representatives and others that the
previous committee uh worked quite
extensive quite extensively with
uh do we have uh no can we not have
discussions in in the uh we have had
quite extensive discussions with
Department of Environmental Services in
shaping this bill also the New Hampshire
Municipal Association get their
objections handled and we did all of
that I'm really disappointed to see
commissioner Scott come out with a
letter
today when he had all this time to
address this when it was in the previous
committee um and I just want to say that
that this isn't the first time I've had
commissioner Scott come up with
something at the last minute which could
have addressed it much sooner um I would
say I want this bill passed if the
Senate's working on a different version
come to either Committee of conference
or something uh to work it out uh or we
adopt the Senate's version at the end
but I want to move this forward uh and
uh let's uh representative PL let's keep
the comments to the specifics in the
bill I I understand your passion on this
I think you can bring that up in the
work session thank you I just want to
State my displeasure with commissioner
Scott not coming up with this a month
ago thank
you um okay I'm going to close the
public hearing on HB
1429 we have one more Bill to he I'll
open the public session on hb1
1626 relative to the repeal of certain
designated funds and I don't have any I
do have a pink card uh representative uh
and you're right
there representative Maguire thank you
Mr chairman members of the committee for
the record my name is Dan Maguire I
represent the town of Epsom I was the
chair of the joint committee on
dedicated funds which uh you were a
member and your ranking member was our
clerk the most useful member of the
committee by far are and um so that this
was in September and October we we uh
this committee examines all dedicated
funds and reviews them on a fiveyear
cycle so this particular year uh we
reviewed funds from the agriculture
Department the department of
administrative Services insurance
department and so on several others and
um this bill in front of you is the
result and most of this is very very
minor this is not Millions this is at
most thousands in in some cases much
less so
um I can you know go through it it's
it's mostly little tiny cleanup things
funds that have had no revenue or
expenses for years and and we're getting
rid of them or in some cases combining
them with other funds that are uh that
are used for these very minor things but
um this is sort of on the edge of of
technical corrections I guess the most
interesting part is this dog license fee
thing and that's why this bill comes to
you not as a first committee but as a
second committee so it already went
through environment and agriculture
specifically for the dog license part of
it so I'm happy to answer questions
thank you representative Edwards uh
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative McGuire for taking my uh
question um
I fir first a little background I I I
want to say that um when you're doing it
uh modifications software updates uh it
takes a period of time for an analyst to
take a look at the software uh plan what
they're going to code check with people
about what they're going to code then
they code then after it's coded it goes
to quality assurance and then it gets
tested before it goes live and then
there's a go live and so the
administrative managerial overhead of a
software update is actually fairly
significant and so my question is as I
look at the the pennies involved here
and your comment that this may be
influences a few thousand doll it it my
instinct on this is that um while it may
make it more precise it's not worth the
investment it just doesn't Reach the the
the the cost benefit stage and this is
particularly important because our it
department is is overloaded with it
projects that they're working on and so
finding the analyst time and all is is
sort of a challenge anyways so so my
question sir is um in in your managerial
Instinct does this pass the common sense
test is this is this worth chasing a few
pennies at the cost of of all of that
analyst time um well thank you for the
question but I I guess I must have given
the wrong impression because this is not
about it this is about dedicated
so can you can you explain but all of
these funds are supported by some it
somewhere that that there that there's
somebody who's collecting this money and
and it and it can't and it's got to be
automated to some extent does it not or
am I just completely missing this if I
am I I yeah I I don't think so I mean I
think there's um so first of all these
are like bank accounts right and so
having an extra one or not an extra
one is maybe makes a little bit of a
change to the way the comproller does
her job right but it's it's like having
another bank account or not it's it's
not not um there's not a lot of
programming or something like that
involved so no I I think the answer is
basically no I I don't think this is not
a huge thing to to eliminate one or add
one or so on and especially because they
exist right there there there's sort of
an ongoing bank account there and and it
has static money in it for example in
many of these cases right so it has $300
or it has $1,000 or it has something and
so we're just deciding let's get rid of
this so we don't have to think about it
anymore and and move on right
so so no I I mean I was a software
manager so I I appreciate all the you
know what you just said but it's it's
really not that I don't think
representative PL yes I see this drops
the fee for license for dog from $2 to
$1.75 and it increases the amount that
the clerk send to the Department of
Agriculture markets from0 50 cents to 75
cents so the differences coming out of
the Town municipality pocket they won't
be too pleased about that what what's
the justification thank thank you for
the question but no that's not so so
currently um
$2.50 from the dog license fee goes to
two State programs there's a split right
currently $2 goes to one particular
State program and 50 cents goes to the
other state program this bill simply re
jiggers the split so that $1.75 goes to
one state program and and 75 cents goes
to the other state program and that's
because um uh the one was running a
little short of funds that's the veter V
Veterinary Diagnostics laboratory it's a
lab that that does mostly rabies tests
but other kinds of tests I think too and
the and the other one was the spay and
neuter program which was having an
excess of funds so this actually doesn't
change what happens in in Towns at
all thank
you represent Aly you're on the bill did
you want to make any
statements I just wanted to say that the
fiscal note was not sent to
it on that we have had fiscal notes that
did talk about the cost of on
re uh REM managing the deck chairs and
in this case
um the laboratory fund is
important on
for on
finding on
population so the fact that it's been
short changed and that the other one was
swimming in money is a was a problem
yeah okay maybe I should have been up
there to say
that Mr chairman I want to that was a
would you believe question since you're
not there thank you U so let me just add
one other thing besides the bill the the
the process of of looking through all
these funds was quite worthwhile in the
sense that that um we we came up with
some ideas for future
legislation that that was not simple
cleanup like this for example um we
discovered that the what we're charging
justices of the peace is about three
times more than needed so so your
Justice of the Peace licenses laps a
bunch of money to the general fund every
year and that's not really appropriate
we generally with licensing we like to
match expenses and and revenue and so
you know for a future bill that gives us
the idea maybe we should lower the fee
for a Justice of the Peace things like
that so there were some other things of
that nature that were found by the
committee but don't exist yet in in
legislation right thank you okay um I
think U represent
fellows so I I have a um something of
the whole section of the statute you
know not just the amended part and and
the part that you can't see if you're
looking at the bill is that the basic
and the the other thing is when you get
down to line 9 it says in my which is
the category I fall into and when I go
to get a dog license I pay in cash and I
bring
$2 and I just think for these tiny
amounts I just don't
see the value of of making those changes
and I and I really think that you know
making like one do rounding everything
off to$ one dollar would to full dollar
would be a better idea just yes thank
you for the question representative yes
as I understand it the fee for a dog
is450 if the dog is neutered and $7 if
it's not um and and there's some break
break for for owners who are 65 or older
but um but it looks like pennies here
but it turns into thousands right the
the the diagnostic
laboratory uh is over $100,000 a year is
that expense and the spay and neuter
program is much more so so it's you know
there's a lot of dogs and cats out there
and so the these little dollar amounts
do turn into into something more
significant I mean there's actual
employees who are you know hired by
those funds yeah the go the goal here as
as the representative had said earlier
was to balance the funds out we are
finding that there was a large imbalance
in these funds and that's why these
numbers while if you just look at the
number by itself it looks silly but it
actually does add up to to to thousands
I mean during the committee I personally
suggested that we put the $2.50 sense in
one of the funds eliminate the other one
and pay both expenses out of that fund
so therefore we'd never have to think
about this again but the rest of the
committee didn't well and I think the
department didn't like that idea because
because the two uses of the fund are
very separate as far as the department
goes so they like the fact that there's
two funds and that's why we're here
today thank you I have a copy of our
report um I'll give to your clerk if
anybody wants to sounds it all right and
we'll talk more about this this
afternoon um I'd like to I'd like to
wrap up this public hearing unless there
is a final
question thank you okay seeing none
thank
you is there anyone else who like would
like to testify on hb1
1626 seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing on hb1
1626 okay so as you all know um at 1:00
we start our work session on these work
sessions on these five bills um and so
the time being um 12:22 and I'm assuming
people might want to have some lunch uh
why don't we come back and start the
work session at
1:10 we'll come back at 1:10 and start
sessions okay any questions before we go
we will be having an exec session today
uh we will have an exec session we're
have a work session on the five bills
and then I set 1:30 obviously it's going
to be a little later than 1:30 but
whatever bills of those five we feel
like we can exec I would like to get
them out of the committee if possible if
that's not possible we will schedule
another time for whatever bill that is
um yes Mr chairman I take just a moment
of the committee's time before you or
adjourn for lunch um so I'm
representative hacken Phillips and I
come to you from the car committee on
Friday morning we had um a rule um
review of some issues that affect
Department of Safety and I wanted to let
you and the ranking member know that jel
car has a suggested legislative fix for
water safety rules um that I'll be
approaching you both about shortly um
and I just wanted to give you a heads up
um we do believe that this is necessary
and we'd like to see if we could get it
worked in as a first and only first
committee bill before our deadlines
approach um so I did send you and
ranking member Al me an email this
morning about the issue and I would just
um I'm hoping that we can open a
dialogue about that shortly so thank you
for the preview thank
n
e
and uh we will now start our full
committee work sessions we're going to
start with uh HB 1179 so I'll open that
now do I have comments questions
representative PL this has minimal
Revenue impact and it's a good thing to
do I see no problem with passing this
bill personally thank you Rosen
elme I just wanted to know if there's
anybody yet from the uh Park
service is anyone from the park service
here doesn't look like it I would say no
um and it it sounds like uh based on our
public hearing it sounds like the
uh we're looking at a revenue hit of
potentially uh five 5K roughly 55 5500
okay um so it's it is fairly minimal yes
representative selfworth yes I could
support it I would like though the
department to verify that because I feel
like we should have gotten something
from them
you know that that number isn't in their
report it's in someone else's and I
would like their you know I'd like them
to just verify that but I'm willing to
support the bill okay can we
um so I'm not saying to wait wait now
but I'm just saying I think they really
should verify it yeah okay represent
Aly yes I'm willing to vote for it with
the understanding that it goes to the
Senate next and that
on the Park service will show up if it
is as much as they claimed okay because
that's a significant amount of
you anybody else comments
questions okay seeing none I'm going to
close the work session on HB
I'll now open the work session on HB
1391 allowing new vehicles purchased in
the model year or
before to be inspected in the second
purchase representative plat does this
need an amendment before we can pass it
because the fee is in law and so we have
to do something about that uh uh at
least say that uh
a reminder that the law needs to be
Revisited if this passed to change to
amount and the the amount you would
wanted um representative spillsbury do
you have a
comment no I'm
confused we're we're talking about uh
the exemption from
inspections what has to change in
amount so when they talked about uh 25
cent uh you know roughly if it was if
the fee was increased 25 cents that
would make up for the
shortfall um that fee the current fee of
$325 is in the statute in RSA 2 266
colon
2 so if that if that does need to be
increased by 25 cents then um we would
have to uh make a change to 262 colon 2
question I think that was the yeah
represented Southworth I mean it would
just seem if this passes that they
cannot increase it by 25 cents they just
have to keep it the way it is right
unless and until the law is changed
right so it I guess in some way or at
some level it doesn't stop us from from
moving forward but there'd have to be
the recognition that that shortfall
Ames I'd like to uh hold the
bill um to give time for us to receive
to receive the uh what was it
commissioner
Scott's um written testimony to the
first
committee um to be sure
to
satisfy the question of whether there
are there's some part of that opposition
that translates to cost uh and um should
be of concern to ours us we've really
received very little
information um other than the knowledge
that the the public safy safety
department opposes this bill and I'd
like to have a full understanding of
that before uh uh going forward with
this bill as is or maybe determining
there some aspect of it that uh uh that
does impact on um the
particular Focus that we have as a
second
committee
represent is representative Scott uh not
representative Scott
um Commissioner of of um safety I don't
believe he's Scott Dees Commissioner of
sty
oh
okay um right yes was in PL I understood
the opposition was just that any
reduction inspections has a safety issue
attached and the question for this
committee is it serious enough to do
anything about uh or to oppose the bill
but that's all if it was any reduction
whatsoever they'd be
opposed I I think he he if I remember
correctly he did say that if you looked
at just the numbers you would see that
there were very few numbers but I think
didn't he make the point of if you had a
family of four and a car and it was was
something wrong with it then that's for
people who could be injured um so I
think to your point representative PL
yes I think he was saying any any
reduction in inspections could
potentially be a safety issue so it's
it's we have to figure out uh as a
committee I guess where that balance
might be although yeah representative
Ames yeah I think my point is this is
this is a significant
change um it is I mean whether you like
it or don't like it it's saying no
inspections for new cars to find in the
statute for two years and that's a
significant difference from the
situation today let's be sure uh that
we're doing this right let's take a
little more time and uh get the
information that we know is out there
and uh then make a judgment about
it I I don't um I I think getting
information is is good but are are you
are we focusing on the policy at that
point when the policy's already been
passed and we're supposed to look at
what is the cost at this point that's uh
I I understand that and uh I don't know
as I I said at the beginning whether the
objection um is just some blanket idea
about uh uh Public Safety or whether it
I I did not hear a fiscal issue that
this committee is going to spend more
time on productively but uh I leave it
up to the chair and everybody else
whether we need to defer
271 uh fails on
78,2
inspections well I think we also heard
that those fails were mostly glass
um uh represent Bolton what was that
tires yeah so it's U the vehicle info
was um glass is 139 tires 77 rear lights
24 wipers 21 okay so the bulk of those
are all
yeah okay anything else representative
Erie yeah I might remind that uh you can
have your car inspected and it can pass
inspection on day one and on day two
it's
failed represent
elme yes on I think that it's a der
elction of Duty for us if we decide that
the highway fund will be out the number
of vehicles which I don't happen to know
offand uh times 25 cents um if uh the
sticker price is not also put up by 25
us so um would you does that imply yes
represent and just to follow up on that
if you buy a brand spanking new car and
the dealer inspects it you can get up to
18 months of inspection
today all this does is say okay we're
going from 18 months to 24
months that's depending on when your
birthday falls correct uh yeah depending
like I said you can get up too you can
get a year plus six
months
okay repr Aly did you
have I did not quite understand talking
about
so would you like to
elaborate well it depend So when you buy
a car if it's if if your birthday is
let's say is in June and you bought it
in January you actually have until you
don't have to inspect it in June you can
go all the way to the next June as it is
now so there there's the EXT that
example might be 17 months but that's
the general
idea representative leapley thank you Mr
chair
um there's rightly been an emphasis on
Revenue because that's our role um yet
when we have a revenue question as with
the the first bill we discussed we don't
have we have you know parentheses and
some math some different people did and
then on the bill that we're discussing
now there was an offer to to make it
more Revenue neutral but that would
require an amendment and our response
was like yeah that's going to take too
much time so it feels like we want to
limit our discussion to revenue yet when
we have questions about Revenue the
response on the last two bills has been
like yeah that's not a big deal so are
we considering the revenue impacts of
these bills it feels like we we kind of
want to EXA today and so we're not
pausing to maybe collect the revenue
information that we need if if that
indeed is supposed to be the function of
this committee no I mean we're not going
to we're not executing for the sake of
executing if if people feel that we
should add an amendment that that
changes RSA
266 colon 2 increasing it by 25 cents to
make up that difference then you know
then we can do
that so I'll leave it up we'll leave
we'll see where the committee falls on
that representative
PL I was happy to pass it as is uh it's
with a small Revenue impact on it but uh
if it makes people on the committee well
uh ways of Means Committee more likely
to pass it I'm willing to put an
amendment in to uh do that raise the fee
25 cents uh for the inspections uh it's
so it's in the same bill so the revenue
reduction is offset by a revenue
increase yeah
okay representative fellows I'm just
wondering if anybody knows when the last
time the the fee
for inspection was put you know when it
would have been set at the four what are
four 425 or whatever it is now when that
was
know how do people feel in general about
um adding an amendment to to get 25
cents back if we're passing ing this
that okay well representative Southworth
remember 25 cents was um a um an
estimate of the likely change because
they really don't have exact figures
yeah somebody said 25 and I think
another person had come out with 23
cents yeah it's somewhere in that
ballpark so again if we are going to do
an amendment you know let's just make
sure we have close to the right amend
yeah and not just an estimate that we
heard you know right I mean I do agree
with representative leapley I think we
do have to dig a little bit more into
the revenue on this committee to make
okay all right anything
else okay close the work session on
looking it wasn't handed out this is the
only
copy um
Susan
oh
uh the fee for the sticker was last
changed in 09 assuming that it wasn't
another
change that that's quite a while ago yes
maybe we should a lot of inflation AG go
yeah just adjusting for inflation would
more probably more than cover the 25
whatever
Senator PL my offer to put an amendment
is just so it's Revenue neutral out of
this bill we're looking at changing the
fee structure entirely I think that's
next year when we look we look at all
fees and revenues and see whe the what
what the needs are but I haven't heard
any push that this was needed to be
increased at all um that that it's
covering the costs and that's that's
what needs to be happen frankly I
wouldn't worry so much about the revenue
loss except it's hitting the highway
fund which is uh pretty slim as it be is
so I that's why I'm accepting the idea
we may need an
amendment
okay thank
you all right um I'm going to open the
work session on hb1
1278 relative to qualifying medical
conditions for the purpose of
therapeutic
cannabis represent Al me oh sorry I just
had that on but um I think we are all in
favor of passing it the way it is
is you're in favor of passing it the way
it is um yes it on they're totally
self-regulating they'll lower fees if
this brings in enough money that they
okay
comments okay saying none we'll close
1278 I'll now open the work session on
hb1
1429 establishing a procedure for the
Department of Environmental Services to
transfer ownership of dams and uh I can
guess what representative PL might say
but I'll recognize him so he can say it
all right thank you Mr chair I want to
apologize for my strong feelings earlier
but uh I did did not appreciate getting
this letter the day of uh we're uh
having the uh hearing and the work work
session because we we could have had it
quite a while ago and worked on it
wasn't with in the last committee right
now we have two choices like we can
delay this exact because we got until
March sometime I asked you foret and and
try to get the language that's being
drafted in the Senate into our version
that's one op option the other is to
just pass it it'll go to a committee of
conference and accept the Senate's
version essentially either way it
works
else yeah representative Bley um is did
anyone from the municipal
Association
come no from the what Municipal yeah um
is there anyone from Municipal
Association
no yes I'm sorry followup no she may I
answer oh sure yeah not here but they
did come when was in in the the last
committee resources or whatever it was
and they did impact the bill to make
certain that their concerns were taken
were I guess I still have concerns
looking at the letter um that this bill
would impact not
only dams owned by nhdes but also other
departments and it sounds like that
consideration so I guess what I'm saying
is I would I I think it makes sense to
to hold on to this a little bit to see
if we can answer the
questions May respond again sure I it
may make sense to delay it because there
dams that not owned by thees but by
other state agencies we have to exempt
them but new New Hampshire Municipal
Association had no concern uh with
respect to they didn't even think about
the dams not owned by Dees they just
wanted to make certain that the language
covered Municipal concerns which uh and
so it does so that that the two are not
related New Hampshire Municipal
Association and the uh dams that are not
agreed representative
AMS yeah I guess I'm coming out on the
side of more time for more than just the
first bill I spoke of uh but I'd like to
uh have a little more time to uh to
determine whether we really should in
order to act
responsibly um make an amendment to this
bill to catch the issue that was maybe
too maybe late in the game but
nonetheless it's in front of us that's
been identified by
uh by whoever by the uh U Dees and um by
Scott I'll use the name um and uh and
figure out if we can uh if we can
identify it uh what what needs to be
amended I think it's pretty simple
Amendment as I understand it and and um
then uh we'll have something we can go
forward with with confidence and uh
maybe uh we won't have to go through a
conference committee with the senate in
the end because we'll all be together on
the same page and that would be good
okay represent fellows um I have
concerns about the potential impact on
property values in a particular
community and I think that one of the
things it's not covered in here is I
think that um removing a a dam that's on
a river and as long as that wouldn't
cause any flooding issues that might be
okay and the community might want to do
something about that but the prospect
that this could be used that would take
down a dam that would lower the level of
water on a lake and have a major impact
on the values of homes on that property
that I that to me that is like very
wrong and so maybe there needs to be
some kind of Distinction in here that
covers that situation that says you know
provided there there's no impact on
property values or provided the
municipality certifies that it's that
they're good with it just I just have
concerns related to that and it may not
be an impact on Revenue to the state but
it could you know that does impact
Revenue to
municipalities and certainly a huge huge
U Financial uh impact on anybody who has
a property that would be impacted by any
change resident PL If This Were a dam
being taken down in the middle of
nowhere within a Incorporated Township
and so that the uh water levels Reed but
nobody lives there nobody cares and the
uh municipality would not be willing to
buy the dam from the state to just let
it happen the case in gsan and many
other communities that this will
eventually be affected by it's huge
because we there are properties on
lakefront property they will no longer
be lakefront property the the property
value will be significally impacted the
recreational value to the town goes down
so we very much care and and the town
has the option of uh in that case of of
buying the land from the state and
getting a loan to be able to take care
of whatever it needs to to to keep the
pro process going um so that's a
decision to be made but the fact that
it's voluntary by the town I think takes
care of your concern they'd have to have
significant economic impact before the
town would
care my understanding is right now like
if this didn't exist the state can
dismantle a dam as it is now so it's not
like you pass this now you create that
problem it the problem you're talking
about is already
Ames yeah I think U this illustrates why
we shouldn't stray too far into policy
matters that are beyond our
jurisdiction I'm sure there are
processes and rules and limitations on
um that are uh go into a decision to
remove a dam
and uh we're you know that's beyond our
ability to um get in well maybe it's not
beyond our ability but we shouldn't get
into that there are others that
are able to do that so um I think onest
face this is an option that uh this
enables a process that uh right now
um may be something that could be
pursued but it's difficult uh allows
municipalities to have a voice and an
option but it doesn't mandate anything
along those lines it does mandate that
the uh Dees look at that
option um and so um on his face it looks
good except for the uh need for some a
couple of amendments that have been
flagged late late in the game but we
need to look at
them thank
you any anybody else represent uh
Aly thank you on what bothers me about
this is the money for the dam
maintenance revolving Loan Fund which um
it has been brought up by the department
that uh any money that Finance might
move into this would probably come off
of the money for the dam maintenance
fund which is already in existence which
is totally underfunded and which deals
with the high-risk dams that are likely
to kill
people so
um
on
frankly from my perspective assuming
that the finance committee um did its
job on on on priorities for this um if
this goes in to 612 as a dedicated fund
it'll probably sit there for 5 years
unless there's some big Federal grant
that comes through um and then we would
repeal it if I'm still here other people
would repeal it if I'm not because
there's no
money dams in general have no
money no damn
money representative spillsbury
thank you Mr chairman my comment uh
is very much in sync with what
representative Aly has just forecast and
that's as I stated earlier during the
hearing that this bill without an
Associated
appropriation doesn't really do anything
the department right now can
voluntarily uh get in contact with the
town and offer them an option and give
them a year so the purpose of requiring
the department to make the offer
it doesn't change what they can do now
it's just associated with the whole
mechanism of a financing well if we're
not going to fund a loan a revolving
Loan Fund the bill doesn't do
anything I I don't particularly see the
purpose of passing this
bill representative PL do you have
something to say yes I very much do it's
enabling you're right that if the
finance committee next year doesn't do
squat with it the bill will eventually
uh the the the dedicated fund that we're
establishing will go away by this
committee after after several years if
the finance committee doesn't fund it
but if without this enabling legislation
the finance committee's got nothing to
fund and so I that you need the
dedicated fund established with a dollar
in it so the finance committee can re
respond to Dees requests next year and
in future years just it's not clear to
me what this enables
today right well I think what
representative Spiller is saying the
town of gtown for example could go ahead
now the difference with this bill would
be if it's funded then there's a funding
mechanism if it's not funded we could go
Bond anyway uh but but this may be a
better mechanism we want to establish
the dedicated fund so the finance
committee has something to act on next
year if this if the dedicated fund isn't
there finance committee doesn't have
anything to act on because it's what
this committee establishes the dedicated
funds not finance representative Edwards
yeah thanks thanks Mr chair I just want
to point out that the budgeting process
starts with the governor's budget and
and so we we're talking about finance
committee pushing this but but the
governor's budget would have to have
something in it in nearly all
circumstances we rarely step in and
finance something that the the governor
mentioned
okay anything
else okay seeing none we'll I'll close
1429 I'll now open the work session on
hb1 1626 relative to the repeal of
certain Des um designated
funds
and do I have any comments on this
one representative Ames I think this is
ready to
go
okay yeah I'm
sorry representative Aly as a as a
co-sponsor are you on board with ready
to go oh yes okay
all right um any other comments
questions seeing none oh representative
no okay I'm going to close the uh work
session on HB
efficient okay so um it's 10 of
two um
I think we're going to um allocate a
little bit of time to a
caucus um and um 10 of two we probably
need I don't think we need too much time
maybe 15
minutes so why don't we come back at uh
between 2 205 205 uh at the latest to
get back and we'll start 205 will start
our exec
session thank
may we are in recess at the present time
205 I guess yeah the Republican caucus
will meet in here and uh did you want me
to announce where the Democrats are are
meeting in the hall in the hall follow
representative only yeah well we've been
evicted
yes to go we'll keep it
short um little green I would
unfortunately I have to ask that all
members um uh in the uh seats also leave
motion hold on one
second
need okay recognize representative PL
for a motion I move ought to pass on
House Bill 1179
FN do I have a second second Mr
chairman
uh would you like to speak to your
motion very simply it's a it's a a break
for veterans who deserve the break and
the the cost is minimal $5,000 is what I
heard so it's it's a no no-brainer to
discussion representative
Aly I still am worried because the park
service is very underfunded always
on on about what this fiscal note really
is we have no official fiscal note or
anything from the Department uh about
this and we just heard um
from the dees group here that they don't
get notified when we're receiving these
bill bills and they only found out about
it after the calendar came out on Friday
which is why that letter was so late
um but uh and the original fiscal note
was looks minor to people here
but 16,000 or something like that would
take care of a fair on of Maintenance in
the Park Service buildings that go
unmaintained so um I'm going to vote for
it with the understanding that they will
find out about the Senate
hearing and can come into
that but okay uh I think we need to do
something about notifying agencies for
second committee
bills thank
you representative
yes uh thank you Mr chair I'm going to
go ahead and vote I I'm just a little
uncomfortable because I'm a veteran a
retired veteran and so i' I'd be a
beneficiary of this I I think it's uh di
Minimus but I thought I'd let people
you okay seeing no more discussion I'm
going to ask the clerk to call the rooll
chairman Jinan yes uh representative
Edwards yes repres
yes representative duet yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes representa
sodi yes representative cambrils yes
representative Mooney yes representative
roord yes representative Aly yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
representative shanberg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative
leapley she's not
here leapley is not here okay uh
representative Smith
yes okay it's uh the vote is 19 to zero
with one not
voting the vote being uh unanimous at 19
to Zer any objection to
consent I'll close the ex session on hb1
1179 next I'll open the exec session on
HB
1391 allowing new vehicle
purchases year to be inspected in the
second year after purchase and I will
recognize representative spillsbury for
a motion thank you Mr chair I move OTP
on HB
second second
sod and uh representative spillsbury
would you like to speak to your
motion um yes thank you uh I think
there's been some discussion about uh
whether or not we need to uh uh revise
the sticker fee um I don't think that
uh we've had any testimony indicating
how we would do that at what figure we
would do it I think representative Aly
has fairly raised the question about
passage of time since it was last
adjusted but I think we can go ahead and
pass the
Bill let this go into effect and let the
uh Department of Safety uh come back to
us in the next session and tell us
whether an adjustment is uh is warranted
and and what adjustment that might be in
the meantime we need to remember that
U this is not a a uh a fee or a program
that's designed to raise revenue to fund
the state it's simply a fee to cover the
cost of
administering and uh we're going to let
roughly 880,000
Vehicles a year take a pass for two
years um without having to worry really
about safety issues so the revenue
consequence is minimal and the
adjustment can be made at a later
date
represent
elme thank you I'm going to vote no on
this if we have to vote on it now um
because it is much harder in A
legislature in which one party is
condemned by the other party in public
for raising taxes and fees all the time
uh to um pass an increase separate from
the need for it which is created by this
bill in order to to maintain even the
level that we were at in
09 so
um so I I personally
disagree representative
fellows um I would just like to ask
representative spillsbury to
explain um his statement that the money
raised from this is just to support the
inspection program because in the fiscal
note I see that part part of the money
goes to the highway fund part to general
abatement sure um representative fellows
glad to clarify I think your question is
valid I didn't mean to say that the
highway fund gets no benefit from the
fees what I did mean to say is that we
revenue okay thank you
um
Ames yeah I'm going to vote no on this
uh because I think uh there is no need
to act today on this bill we've got
until mid-march or
so um and um we know there's more
information out there the uh Department
of Public Safety has uh given written t
testimony to the first committee um
expressing their opposition to the bill
now much of that opposition undoubtly
isn't based on policy issues that are
beyond the uh reach of this committee
but um I'd like to see that testimony
and make sure that it does not uh impact
the U the kinds of issues that this
committee is uh is uh here to adjust so
I'm I see no reason for going forward on
this bill and if we have to go forward
I'm going to vote
no okay representative fellows
or I we I think I already had gone to
else okay um seeing no more discussion
I'll ask the clerk to call the role
chairman janigan yes representative
Edwards yes representative oler yes
representative duet yes representa
spillsbury yes representative plots yes
representative sodi yes representative
cambrell yes representative Mooney yes
representative rord yes representative
Aly no representative Ames no
representative Southworth no
representative Malloy no representative
shamberg
yes representative fellows
no representative Bolton no
Representative elberger no
representative leapley not here oh
representative Smith no okay the vote is
11 in favor eight against and uh one not
voting let's see uh is that
right yeah eight yeah one not voting 11
eight
you it's close but I don't think we'll
put this one on consent okay I'm going
to close the executive session on HB
1391 I'll now open the exec session on
HB 1278 relative to qualifying medical
conditions for the purposes of
therapeutic cannabis and recognize
motion I move out to pass onh House Bill
12778 do I have a second
second representative
elberger and would you like to speak to
your motion representative
Aly yes
um this bill is essentially policy we
have confirmed that um any money which
is raised by an increase in
users will get plowed back if not needed
for the expenses into lowering the cost
for the
users and um
therefore
um
else okay seeing no more discussion I
role when he's done
writing
all right the motion being ought to pass
uh representative janigian yes
representative Edwards yes represent
erery yes representative ducet yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative plat votes yes
representative sodi yes represent camell
yes represent Mooney yes representative
rfit yes representative Aly yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes represent Malloy yes
representative shamberg yes
representative fellos yes representative
Bolton yes representative elberger yes
representative
leapley not here uh I'll remember that
eventually representative Smith yes okay
the vote is 190 one not voting the vote
being 19 to zero and any objection to
consent seeing
none do you have an objection I'm sorry
I'm just being contrarian for a moment
um and you can overrule this easily I
this this feels like such a
consequential policy issue that I wonder
if we should have it on consent and and
I I'm just I'm just thinking out
loud I would say no because um the
policy committee has already ruled on
this um so the the the
consequential of the revenue side seems
Seems diminus
dious um unless anyone else has a issue
consent close the exact session now on
HB
1278 uh the next one HB 1429 we are not
going to to exec um uh there's more time
needed there uh representative PL is
going to work on an amendment and he can
work with uh others uh who who may want
to see a change there Senator Murphy's
drafting the Senate's that other body
shouldn't be saying uh Senate the other
body is working on the amendment we'll
just take the same language and put it
in this
one okay
um so the last uh last bill we have to
exec is um I'm going to open the exec
session on HB
1626 and recognize representative Aly
motion I move out to pass on House Bill
second thank you represent ol
s would you like to speak to your motion
representative omy
sure um this bill is primarily concerned
with the repeal of a few dedicated funds
that had lost all reason for
existence
um I was asked a question about the one
that removed the pesi training program
they had uh in agriculture they had
moved the pesticides tra training
program over to UNH and let them get the
fees um so having having a non-existent
program was not in the cards um and and
then the other half of this is making
changes to the licensing of dog fees not
at the license level but at the level uh
uh not at the level of municipality
versus State portions but at the level
of how much of of that joint fee goes to
um Animal
Control uh fees that is spay a neuter
and how much of it goes to this state um
on lab uh Veterinary Diagnostic lab um
uh the
latter has been doing less um work
checking for acade EP
epidemics uh and than they had been
doing before because we weren't giving
them enough money and we weren't giving
them enough money because it had been
set in statute how much went there and
how much went to the spay and neuter the
spay and neuter has been having Less
business uh over the years because I
think of the success of the program um
in reducing the wild
populations and uh and they had too much
money so we moved the money sources so
that span neuter got less and um the
animal population control uh got less
and and the diagnos IC lab got more they
also Diagnostic lab as I remember also
had uh has had his expenses grow because
of inflation and the costs of chemicals
and
[Music]
things thank
comments seeing none I will ask the
rooll on Bill 1626 FNA the motion being
ought to pass uh chairman janigian yes
representative Edwards yes represent
erery yeah representative duet yes
represent spillsbury yes rep
representative ples yes representative
Mooney yes representative
uh sodi yes represent uh cambrell yes
represent roord yes represent Aly yes
represent Ames yes represent Southworth
yes represent
yes represent shanberg yes represent
fellows yes represent Bolton yes
represent elberger yes representative
leapley is not here uh I remember this
time representative Smith yes so it's
voting the vote being 19 to zero any
consent okay seeing none then we'll put
that on consent as well Mr chairman yes
uh the on uh on
Bill if I get the right with 1291 the
vote was 1181 will there be a Minority
Report and by whom 1391 1391 okay the uh
majority report is representative
is representative Ames will do the
Minority
Report
okay I'm going to close the exact
1626 that concludes uh our schedule for
today um there is no there are no
meetings scheduled for next week um the
watch the calendar for the week of
March uh 4th I'm planning on scheduling
things for March 5th and 6th Tuesday the
5th and Wednesday the 6th
um I don't know the time right now it's
probably 10:00 well Tuesday will be 10
o'clock because I know you guys have a
conflict um
so that's about it any uh any questions
or
you